hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the Halloween
now this is a game that is made by the
same people that made the house in the
house too so they should be pretty
similar thematically but let's get to it
okay I don't know if you can see my
mouse or none it just went dark
hi okay can I have the lights I got to
make you coop coop
I can't even click on that I just kind
of hover over in this Boop
okay so in the house and the house -
basically what you would do is you would
you would click around until you find
something that it wants you to show you
and usually usually what it wants to
show you something horrific and jump
scary so wait I mean I heard something
when the lights were off there was there
actually something happening there or
were you just doing that to be Kyle eyes
my god I go okay okay so thunk thunk
okay so yeah that what is that okay hi
okay Thung usually these games that I
remember the sound is obviously very
very good so I get the lights down as
low as possible in the volume cranked up
why high in my headphones my nice
surround sound headphones hahaha oh
you're adorable
look at you you're like the cutest
bumpkin I've ever seen by my turn the
light back on the boys nobody happened
to wait a minute but some down here I
didn't get for haha October 31st 2010
Halloween is an annual celebration
observed on October 31st primarily in
the United States Canada Ireland in the
United Kingdom it has roots in the
Celtic festival of Samhain the Christian
holiday of All Saints ad but is today
largely a secular celebration common
Halloween activities include
trick-or-treating wearing costume ghost
tours bonfires Apple boxing visiting
haunted attraction telling ghost stories
or other friend ales watching horror
films are playing the house thins I
studio those are the guys that made this
game
well I remember my closet being open
okay whatever oh the lights won't go out
again turn the lights out oh that's
probably not a good thing okay
like in the house ha ha ha good work on
that audio seriously that like it
wrapped around my head might a dip in my
I hear that I know cute little dinghy
did you hook oh yeah tonight I got
sender my gun what are you doing to me
what are you doing to me are you due to
be game are you doing to me
ah you're so adorable but I hate you
hahahahaha why it's no one shoot a gun
full of blood Oh God oh that's different
scan this thing on favorite hang on I
got a I got an app on my phone for this
and let's see this alright I'll play
your game
you broke what does it lead to
Oh at least in their Facebook page okay
all right that's hey that's cheating you
can't do that that's actually really
clever so good for you I mean no likey
this game middle likey window lot okay
it's weird like randomly the light
switch will not work and I got my god
things lurking in the darkness I wonder
that's Jane hide in the dark and under
the bed I'm not clicking on that thing
that isn't that baby head I'm not like
another dead baby end oh oh that's
disgusting
good that is gross okay oh hi wait a
minute
I see something wait there's a little
tiny itty bitty something I'm not sure
okay okay what I'll do okay all right
I'll get going good good
go go go go oh okay that's good
that's great Harding the darken under
the bed what the hell is going on here
oh god I don't want to turn the lights
back on it's off it's the only thing
shits still there
okay now you do ha ha ha hi again
okay Zen ha ha ha ha at the end I don't
remember that face bigger there Oh add
the one on the left in there or the one
in the right or remember the dead baby
boy ha ha ha okay all right oh this
gives you the heebie-jeebies it's ok so
this was a short little something you
can play it for yourself maybe something
different will happen I've heard that in
the house in the house too if you do
things in a certain order they change up
the wasting Josh so maybe something will
be different here I don't know so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Wow
whoa
Oh
Oh
Oh